before we get started a quick reminder
that the bbc is a transphobic
organization platforming people who are
literally calling for the genocide of
trans women if you don't know what i'm
talking about you will find links in a
pinned comment below with my video on
the topic as well as a more recent one
from the youtuber sean and with that out
of the way on with the show
so
kitchen sink we're just kitchen sinking
it at this point
[Music]
[Music]
doctor who flux continues episode three
once upon a time
it's actually kind of bizarre to me that
there has not been a doctor who episode
prior to this that was called once upon
a time we've had twice upon a time but
not once very strange
anyways this is the third episode and
i'm noticing a particularly distinct
pattern at least so far well
the next episode will confirm whether or
not this holds but based off the next
time little thing that we got i'm
feeling kind of confident about it at
least going
this far into it which is that
odd-numbered episodes have been ones
that deal with the overarching stuff
more than anything else and the even
number ones are dealing with not
entirely but something closer to a
self-contained story we saw that in war
of the santarans and that looks like
what we're going to be dealing with with
the
um
weeping angels next time
and that's
fine
all things considered but it does put me
in a position where the odd-numbered
ones i'm just not liking
nearly as much
so
i like this better than the first
episode i'll say that up front it does a
couple of things that help me
gel with it a little bit better for one
uh it actually threw me off right at the
beginning introducing a bell and like
belle's story and like this
young woman who's dodging daleks and
like she's in there i'm like for god's
sake you're throwing in another element
that i don't know why it's here but by
the end of the same episode i understood
why she was here because she connects to
vinder's story
i still don't know if vinder really
needs to be here which
like
okay my general opinion on both vendor
and dan at this point
is that i'm waiting to see why they're
here
and i don't i mean like
in terms of the overall dynamics
from a strictly logistical point of view
they're giving us
roots to additional things i guess
um and allowing for more information to
come in but
you know as someone who very vocally
was looking forward to the idea of just
the doctor and yeah so that i could see
that relationship
deepen
instead throwing in more characters
it feels like in terms of the
inter-character dynamics it feels like
an excuse to not have to deepen the
doctor and yaz's relationship because
there isn't time because we got more
people
but anyways
tangent it a little bit there my point
being by the time this episode was done
i understood why this new element
that had been introduced was here and
that's good considering that there's
some stuff that was introduced back in
the first episode but i still don't know
why that's going on
so
at the very least new stuff brought in
has been justified within the episode it
was brought in
a thank you i appreciate that the other
thing that this did which
i liked but then frustrated me sort of
like in a sideways fashion
i like
that
fugitive doctor
has shown up here
now this uh
largely falls within uh what was kind of
the accepted speculation around a lot of
this which is that with the the ravagers
i guess that's what they are
collectively swarm and azure um
with the ravagers you know having said
that they've faced the doctor before but
she doesn't remember them the obvious
option is that the doctor faced them
while she was the fugitive doctor
because we know she doesn't remember
that
life
we still don't know why or why that
version of the doctor was
um
you know in cahoots with the division or
why that version of the doctor was
called the doctor or had a tardis that
looked like a phone box but did
i i'm i don't know how much hope i'm
gonna hold out that all that gets dealt
with but in any case
i got excited seeing her back and seeing
her in because first of all
joe martin is still damn good in this
part and even in brief glimpses that we
get her god
damn it does she command the screen
she's really really good
and it's frustrating even though i liked
seeing her and i liked actually seeing
things connect back to this which you
know
you did all this stuff dropping bombs
about this
last series and no you're only we're
halfway through you're finally starting
to bring it back in
but
at the same time
it takes up a very small percentage of
the run time of this thing
it feels like one of many threads not
given significantly more weight the
doctor seems to care more about it but
the narrative as a whole doesn't feel
like it's giving her presence that much
more weight and honestly even the
doctor's level of caring about it i'm
still having a hard time parsing
because while i understand the doctor or
anybody wanting to know what about their
own life has been kept from them
when she says things like i need to find
out who i was who i am like you know who
you are
hmm
the the way that they get her worked up
and invested in this i don't
buy so that doesn't help i actually feel
really really bad for jody whitaker in
this episode because she is given
so much exposition like almost nothing
but exposition
in terms of her lines and exposition and
techno babble
and like frequently unnecessary because
like
she pulls
uh she pulls dan and yaz into the time
storm thing
and
they like get thrown out of it oh and
also vendor they get thrown out of it
but then she's like back in it and
talking to the
mori
that's how they said it i think
um
your names for these
aliens suck man
but she's talking to the maury and then
like there's this moment where she's
like i'm getting pulled back out again
thrown back into my own timeline i'm
like
yeah we know we've seen it happen like
three times just do it at this point
why why and it was so clearly an overdub
line too because like the image is her
from the back
and it it was so clunky and it felt
insulting
that it had that they felt the need to
inject that
like
conceptually
i like some of the things going on in
this episode because
some of the episodes i have liked better
during this
era
have been the more
mind bendy slightly more out there ideas
like it takes you away and can you hear
me and on paper this could have been
more in line with those in terms of the
characters jumping along their own past
but it's not quite right it's slightly
different
we learn more about them but it is over
explained so much almost immediately
that any of that air of discovery or
that sense of unease from not being
entirely sure what's going on is gone
almost as soon as it starts happening
because it gets over explained not only
too soon but then repeatedly again after
that
i think i could have gotten a lot more
enjoyment out of this with about
30 to 40 percent of the exposition
trimmed or cut
because i think that the jumping between
timelines and the doctor phasing in and
out of different people's realities and
past and histories
that in and of itself could have been
an interesting thing to try and unravel
and try and follow and try and
you know be with the characters they try
and wrap their heads around what's going
on but again it got over explained
too early and then too often and like
can i just take a hot second and
say how really bizarrely weird it is
for me that
yaz's thing with her sister
is like a complete validation of the
fake gamer girl
idea
concept
that's
i'm just going to say that's kind of
gross
the whole idea of the fake gamer girl um
was was a gatekeeping technique
to keep women out of gaming spaces the
presumption that yo you're not a real
gamer you're pretending to like games
so that guys will think you're cool
which is not really a thing that happens
and just becomes an excuse to bar women
from gaming spaces or did it's not even
really an in-fashion thing to say and
hasn't been for years and yet this seems
to outright validate it
i'm sorry that's kind of screwed up i
don't want to dwell on it so too much
because it's such a small part of the
episode but like
anybody else just me
that felt screwed up
but
like again without the exposition there
the
pace at which things were revealed
felt decent especially within the
doctor's story like the point at which
she looks in the like because you don't
know initially is this just a completely
fabricated reality for her
you know because you know she's there
obviously with people who she would
never be in a combat situation like this
with like dan and yes and then and then
seeing
the fugitive doctor in the mirror and
hearing the reference to
dan being a dog and realizing oh no
it's like projecting these people over
what the actual memory is of and it's
cavanista i think i finally got the name
right
so
like that was kind of cool to follow and
if the overall thing had been more in
line with that sort of letting us
follow and learn with the characters as
opposed to having the doctor dump so
much of the information on both the
characters and us like i honestly i
think
i think the doctor being injected into
the other people's stories
probably shouldn't have been there
i think her jumping in to explain big
chunks of what's going on i think it
would have been better to chuck that
have a more
dreamlike off-putting atmosphere to the
entire thing where it doesn't feel like
she's more or less in control of this
the whole way through
because it does feel like that like it
says you know she's juggling timelines
and like people are saying you know this
is too much for you or whatever but like
as a practical matter that's not what we
see
she's jumping and she's not in total
control but she seems to more or less
have a handle on things she understands
what's going on for the most part i mean
she still doesn't know her full own full
history but for the purposes of this
story she seems to be pretty in control
of it so later on when the mori are like
you know this is too much for you this
will tear you apart i'm like will it
because i have not gotten a proper sense
of strain of this on her
again it's
it's better than the first episode
because i understand more of what it's
doing or at least i see how more of what
it's doing could have worked better
for me at least if you really dig this
that's great like i i really gotta
emphasize that if you have enjoy if you
enjoyed the first episode if you like
this one
i'm envious because i would like to
but right now the second episode is
easily the strongest one for me
with this one coming in second by
default because i just the first episode
just felt like it did not work
at all
for me
and also
it's getting weird to me that this is
called doctor who flux when the flux
itself
feels like an afterthought at this point
like it was a thing that was coming and
it was destructive but the earth was
shielded from it but now we're dealing
with like some post-apocalyptic stuff
going on we're like because in bell's
story she's like in after the flux and
all that so like okay so it came through
and it messed stuff up but obviously the
universe didn't end things are still
around people are still around daleks
and cybermen
are still around so
and it also seems to have like the idea
of stopping the flux at all doesn't even
come up now it's the idea that like time
is the problem which is another thing
that like on paper i kind of like
because it's a kind of
out there more um
sort of sci-fi of the mind trippy
concept the idea of time running wild
and that if time is not controlled and
restrained it just affects things in
such a way that life as we know it
doesn't function
it reminds me a little bit of the
everything is happening at once from the
husband's uh
what was it the husband no the wedding
of river song
but much like that it's a severely it's
an interesting idea that it's severely
underexplored
it's something that they just kind of
say
and they've got the like the time
particles or whatever the little blue
firefly looking things which
that's a terrible effect and like the
first time we saw it outside
like seeing it go in front of the trees
and stuff i looked at that and went that
looks like something from the
freaking
80s
version of doctor who that's a bad
looking effect and i think it's badly
designed because the show's gotten very
good with effects so i think the design
of it is just not working for me it all
just looks
so but like those are going on it's like
oh it's time and time is dangerous like
then like
truly grapple with the idea
of time unraveling or running wild or
whatever it is you want to do but like
they just kind of call it time
is going badly but it's just it's just
this nebulous
stuff
like these
blue particles going around
there's hints and there's glimpses and
there's ideas here that i could find
interesting or find potential in
but
right now they're just not being used
all that interestingly
i will note about the cliffhanger i
didn't talk about the cliffhanger last
time
um
i i i don't like them particularly i
don't like cliffhangers very much in
general that's not even a doctor who
thing but i will say after it was
pointed out to me i did appreciate like
these are very reminiscent of classic
era doctor who style cliffhangers
which is that you know within
the last 30 seconds of an episode either
things escalate quickly to the point
that oh god it's all going to go wrong
or something happens very suddenly that
now we have to deal with so last time it
was
you know the threat of
um
oblivion from swarm and this time it's a
weeping angel just showing up and being
a threat but you know what
as cheap
as that cliffhanger is because
like it just shows up out of nowhere
i
like it was vaguely connected to yaz's
story but no story was strong enough on
its own to really feel like it uh it
justified continuing off
from that but now it's suddenly it's
here and it's endangered ah cliffhanger
like as cheap as that is the idea of a
weeping angel in the tardis kind of a
neat idea
and
i'll be curious to see what the next one
is because the next one at least on
the preview it it is reminding me more
of more war of the santorans in the
sense of it looks like it has a more
self-contained story to tell
which that's what worked better for me
so far in this series
um
vendor's backstory is
it was predictable but it's decently
done he acts it well enough
but
i guess that's the only other thing
there is because we didn't really learn
all that much substance sub
substantively new or important
about
yaz or about dan
we learned a bit about vendor
um but that's kind of it
i just
i feel like this is gonna sound weird i
feel like this should have been looser
like this this
feels like it has been over tightened
too many lines of exposition to be sure
no one is left behind when i think a
certain feeling of unease and
um
uncertainty would have benefited it now
that might sound weird to me given that
i was complaining about how i didn't
understand what was going on in the
first episode except the first episode
wasn't going for a sense of unease it
was just piling crap on top of me
i think you can go into something and
have a
if you balance it right and have just
the right amount of confusion to just
create a sense where the audience
doesn't feel secure
in what's going on
not in a everything like this is all too
much i don't get what's going on but
going on like
i feel like i kind of get what's going
on but something's a little off i feel
like that's the balance that this setup
and these ideas could have struck
but didn't
ah still better than the first episode
we'll see what the next one's like
fingers crossed doctor who flux once
upon a time
what'd you think about it whatever your
thoughts are drop something down the
comments let's talk about i got a
patreon
that's how i pay my bills keep this
whole operation up and running any
amount you're able to support me there
is greatly appreciated but even if you
can't
that's all right
the likes share subscribes help me out
as well but even if you're not up for
that
that's okay too
because at the end of the day
you are the council
i'm just running the meetings so until
next time this council
is adjourned
[Music]
hey if you're sticking around through
the credits might as well hear some
names read out my patreon helps support
this and in particular i want to thank
raven mcbain bookworm mj tracy scrabbit
vincent paul bartolucci kailyn schwartz
edelin robin moore ross schultz shayla
gourlay wanna hear me mispronounce your
name check out the rewards on the
patreon
[Music]
um
[Music]
now
[Music]
oh
[Music]